[Music]  never  [Music]  chase the hot thing whatever it is  that's like trying to catch the wave and  you'll never catch it you need to  position yourself and wait for the wave  and the way you do that  is you pick something you're passionate  about so that's the number one piece of  advice that i give to somebody who wants  to start a company or start a new  endeavor inside of a bigger company  make sure it's something you're  interested in something you're  passionate about missionaries build  better products and so i would take a  missionary over a mercenary any day  mercenaries want to flip the company and  get rich missionaries  want to build a great product or service  and you know one of those great  paradoxes it's usually the missionaries  who end up making more money anyway